zur Präsentation seines neuen Albums
wir Kinder vom Bahnhof Soul and Jan
Delay ins erste Haus am Platz im Kölner
Dom Hotel gibt der der online-kauf Show
Clixoom de sein Interview und stellt
erstmal klar dass er ein großes Problem
mit seiner Musik hat ich bin ich habe er
niemals ab dem Zeitpunkt oder fertig ist
freiwillig irgendwie meine Musik
das Prozent dass etwa zehn Jahre später
habe ich das oder unmöglich mich dann
wäre
aber ich bin sehr enttäuscht würden
niemals war das ist
verschlimmert auch klingt
aber das ist für mich aber da sich das
Landesarbeitsgericht für das Produkt
meiner Arbeit und
das will ich nicht ich will doch in
Pocking nicht mehr an Musik ist so
schön was ich will andere Musiker nicht
wenn ich das sagen darf
dann wenn jemand
wenn jemand den ganzen Tag im Büro
selbst
da freut er sich darauf nach Hause zu
kommen und dann würde sich gern für
ihren Schreibtisch setzen und damit den
Euro aber man sei wird irgendwas anderes
machen
doch in diesen Tagen gegeben Abends vor
dem Computer sitzen und die Charts
checken
am liebsten hätte er wolle noch mal
Platin wie für sein letztes Album
«Mercedes Dance»
doch Platin ist auch nicht mehr das was
es mal war
wenn ich bin überhaupt so eine kleine
leblose CD «Blood and Wine» Mel wegen
veruntreuter
aber abtreten 12
wenn darüber dauern werden
Vierter wurde Polen überführt werden
hier werden kleinteilige Wolf Biermann 5
Ben Khalifa die Route führt beide
Seiten etwas Anlageberater über
richtige
ja in Anführungszeichen in
Niederösterreich Tirol Milch aus einem
etwa 400 Personen oder 2
wobei Jan Delay ist alles etwas anders
aus einem Grafiker gefallen auf Bretter
genagelte CDs ganz bunt gar nicht er hat
einfach so lange nicht wo ich hingehe
müsse das irgendwie geklärt haben dass
wir noch mal richtig aufwendige geil
wenn er schon klar dem machen und davon
erzählen» Erfurth Käufer sein müssen
muss das auch
daher sei nun wichtig darauf sind wie
früher mit Kinderwagen sie Jung und
noch Druck auf Glas und je und so wie
man es kennt
unrichtig schön die sein die Chancen
für ein weiteres mal Platin stehen gar
nicht mal so schlecht
schon am Veröffentlichungstag ist wir
Kinder vom Bahnhof Soul die Nummer eins
Partei Gionis und bei Amazon